Carl how do you get a subject to loosen
up if they're too stiff or rigid during
one of your photography sessions uh well
that's a number of ways um you know
alcohol is a really easy way to go not
always appropriate but you know that's
the other ways are telling jokes stories
I sometimes try to sit down with my
subject talk to them learn about who
they are as a person with what interests
them is superficial as that sounds what
it does allow for spontaneity humor is a
big part of it I don't find myself to be
a overly funny individual but it it does
come out in its own dry way music is
another way whether it be loud or really
really really low music that's a that's
pretty standard approach smells you know
put incense on sometimes obviously I
have little to no problems with people
bringing in their own recreational
devices but yeah usually it's it's it's
it's a combination you read your subject
really what it boils down to regardless
of what of what your what what actual
method you're using communication is
what I is what I really use is is the
primary tool because you in order to get
in a motive portrait you've got to get
them into a zone of some sort and you
can do that with music alcohol we
whatever whatever it might be just to
loosen people up and I find that it's
pretty effective and I also find that a
way to a way to loosen a subject up is
to be honest with them and move on from
a shot if it's not working you know just
just stop you know this isn't working if
you spent 20 minutes setting it up you
know it's just not working let's move
and they tend to at least my experience
has been they tend to respect that and
feel better that you're on it watching
for details making them look as good as
they can
you